so one of the biggest mistakes I did was
the business model and so I started as a
fully open source project and I said I
grew a community and then as we grew we
get to a point where the local Source
business but it didn't work I couldn't
sustain the RND cost and marketing cost
with a product that was basically free
and just selling support and maintenance
on top of it they had to do a pivot on
the business model and switch to what we
call an open core business model where
80 is open source and 20 is for a fee
that has been the best decision of my
life it changed everything since we did
that
because I didn't build a company in the
community on this idea at the beginning
Community fail betrayed and so we've had
a lot of bad marketing and so I believe
the biggest mistakes I have done is not
to to announce to the community that we
will we are open source today but in the
future we will do a little bit of
properties of train in order to sustain
the open source development I don't know
that at the time but I think if I would
have known I would have said maybe one
year to the Department of local
government